COHEN: Good morning, everyone.
For those of you who can't see me, my name
is Abby Joseph Cohen.
I'm the senior investment strategist at Goldman
Sachs, and a very proud member of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
I have the honor today of introducing Dr.
Olivier Blanchard, who is the chief economist
of the International Monetary Fund.
This is such an important time for the global
economy as it has been for the last several
years.
And Mr. Blanchard has been at the IMF in very
important responsibilities during this period.
He has a very distinguished academic career.
I know you all have a copy of his biography.
But he has spent much of his academic career
at MIT, where he has headed the economics
department.
He's also taught at Harvard.
And he has written a textbook with the incoming
vice chair of the Federal Reserve, Stanley
Fischer.
So without further ado, I would like to invite
Mr. Blanchard, one of my favorite macroeconomists,
up to the podium so that we can begin our
discussion.
BLANCHARD: Thank you for inviting me.
What I thought I would do is to give you a
10-minute summary of the update that I gave
two days ago.
Four times a year, the fund is supposed to
indicate how it sees the world.
And I had to do this in snowy Washington two
days ago.
I emphasized three themes.
The first one is the recovery's strengthening.
I was hoping this would make headlines.
And the two numbers -- I'm not going to inundate
you with numbers -- but the two numbers there
that world growth 2013 was 3 percent.
And we predict -- we forecast it to be about
3.7 percent in 2014.
That's a non-negligible improvement, although
it's still far below the more than 4 percent
that we used to have.
The second is that actually we -- this is
largely -- this is a recovery which was largely
forecasted in the sense that our forecast
revisions are very, very small.
We just revised our number for 2014 by 0.1
percent.
Therefore, what happened is very much what
we expected to happen.
Doesn't always happen that way, but it did.
And then the third one is heterogeneity, which
is that it is not the case that all countries
are recovering at the same pace.
There are fairly major differences across
the world.
And it's not only important to know, but they
interact with each other so that we're not
out of the woods, and that there are some
downside risks which strike us as rather serious.
So these are the headlines.
And the question is, well, why is the world
economy recovering?
I found it useful for the past few years to
think of forces pulling the economy forward,
and then forces pushing it back, keeping it
in place.
So you can think of -- I've used this analogy
of accelerator on one hand, and brakes on
the other.
I think it's a useful way of thinking about
it.
So on the accelerator side, I mean, it's clear
that there has been an incredibly strong accelerator
now for many years, which is accommodative
monetary policy, just getting interest rates
to zero, or very close to, was a fairly strong
monetary expansion.
I think we can discuss how much the unconventional
monetary policy, which was pursued thereafter,
how big the effect was.
I think it was not very large.
It was probably worth doing.
But the point is that this has been an incredibly
accommodative monetary policy, which is continuing.
And if you put yourself in, say, 2006, and
I tell you the major central banks are going
to keep interest rates at zero for the next
three or four years, you would have said,
"Well, it is going to lead to overheating
on a scale we've never seen that's going to
lead to inflation or more."
But that's not what we have seen.
So the accelerator is there.
But clearly, it hasn't worked, because -- because
of the brakes.
So it's important to identify the brakes,
and what we argue is that the brakes are slowly
loosening in various parts of the world, so
that the accelerator is getting force.
My list of brakes, would have three main ones.
The first one is fiscal consolidation.
As you well know, the crisis itself, the decrease
in output led to a very large increase in
public debt.
And something had to be done about it.
So fiscal consolidation was needed.
There was the hope by some -- and this was
very much major controversy in, say, 2011,
2012 -- that this fiscal consolidation would
not affect demand too much, would actually
boost morale, and not stand in the way of
a recovery.
There was this notion that if you had really
strong fiscal consolidation, then you would
instill confidence in people, and therefore,
they would spend more, so that the second
effect would dominate the first.
It think this has been thoroughly debunked.
The effect of fiscal consolidation is to decrease
demand, and to decrease growth in the short
run.
So here, I'm not saying that should not have
been done.
It had to be done.
But it clearly slowed down the recovery by
quite a bit.
There's no question, for example, for the
U.S., that last year, fiscal consolidation
played a really important role in leading
to a relatively small growth -- growth number.
So that's the first.
The second is the health of the financial
system, as translated in the credit conditions
that you and I, you know, households and firms,
can get when they borrow.
And that in turn depends on the health of
the banks, and depends on the health of the
borrowers themselves.
And if there's a large spread between the
policy rate, the rate that monetary policy
sets, and the rates at which we can borrow,
then again, that's a fairly major brake on
demand on the recovery.
And then the third is fuzzier, but I think
very relevant.
And in technical terms, we call it "Knightian
uncertainty" for Frank Knight.
And this is this notion that there's uncertainty,
but not of the usual kind; not the uncertainty
where you say there's probably 0.3 that this
will happen, and probably 0.7 that this will
happen, but more the world in which we say,
"I don't understand," which is a different
world from the first one.
And it's clear that this played a very major
role early in the crisis, where what was happening
had never happened, and we couldn't just think
about what was -- I think that, again, that
has played a major role.
What has happened to each of these brakes,
I think, looking into the recent past, and
looking to the future, is they're loosening.
Fiscal consolidation has been not completely
done, but the worst of it has been done in
most countries.
Banks are getting back to health at various
rates.
I think the risks for banks are more in, what
I call, the "second moments," the risk.
But they are still lending at relatively low
rates in many countries.
And I think that type of Knightian uncertainty
is also disappearing.
We're dealing with problems which are more
of a type that we have seen in the past.
So that's the general frame.
And then let me use this to go very quickly
around the world, and tell you where I think
the various countries are.
So for the U.S., my sense is the accelerator
is most definitely still there.
And the brakes are nearly entirely gone; which
is fiscal consolidation, which was strong
last year, is going to still be here this
year, but much less.
I think we've been lucky this time.
Banks -- you know, no bank is in perfect shape.
But banks are lending at low rates so that
people want to get a mortgage or a business
loan, can get it.
So my sense is that the recovery is very strong,
is based on the very wide set of factors.
Private demand is strong.
It was strong last year.
I mean, last year, private demand was 4 percent.
Now, growth was only 2, because of the fiscal
consolidation.
But it was already strong.
I think it's going to get stronger.
So I think the U.S. is really in a solid recovery.
And I don't have much worry about it.
I think that we now can start talking about
an upside risk, which is that -- you know,
think again of the accelerator being on its
own, and the brakes being gone.
It could be that demand is actually stronger
than we currently expect.
This would -- this would be handled -- this
would be handled by the Fed, which would have
to increase interest rates faster than currently
intends to.
But that would create a lot of disruptions
in financial markets.
It's not priced in and would complicate it.
Next, I'm trying to order things.
So the next group of countries where things
are clearly better -- that maybe is going
to sound paradoxical -- I would put the U.K.
and the Euro Core, both Germany and France.
I think if you look at those countries, again,
the accelerator is there, both from the Bank
of England and the ECB.
Fiscal consolidation, which was very strong
in the U.K., has been turned down quite a
bit.
Fiscal consolidation in Germany is non-existent.
They didn't need to consolidate, so they're
not doing it.
And France, which had a lot of fiscal consolidation,
is doing much better this year.
Banks -- again, banks are not in perfect shape.
But in all these countries, they are lending
at low rates.
Their spreads are small.
And so my sense is that although the numbers
are not incredibly exciting yet -- they're
not in the U.S. range -- there is no reason
to think that the recovery will not continue
in those countries.
Continuing, this is the tour.
This is if it's Tuesday, it's Belgium.
The usual, very quick tour of the world.
Japan.
So Japan, the growth numbers are better than
I think anything we had expected two years
ago.
We have about -- about 1.7 percent I think
for 2013, 1.7 percent for 2014.
These are good numbers.
Is the recovery on solid ground?
I think there's still question mark in the
sense that if you look at where the growth
is coming from, it's coming largely from the
fiscal stimulus last year, and largely from
exports; some of it, itself, due to the depreciation
of the yen.
For this to continue, then, you know, it has
to move to consumption, which it has to a
very limited extent.
It has to move to investment, which it has
not.
So there, it could happen.
When you have growth, then consumers eventually
spend more, firms spend more.
But we haven't seen the next step.
And that's a bit worrisome.
Two more remarks on Japan.
You know, whether they reach for 2 percent
inflation that they have committed to is,
from an economic point of view, more or less
irrelevant.
Japan will not be different, whether it's
1.5 or whether it's 2.
Symbolically, it is important.
They have put this as a goal, but it's not
going to make a whole lot of difference.
What counts is output growth, and that comes
from many other things, not just having 2
percent inflation.
And then the point for Japan is really not
growth now.
It's this incredibly difficult balancing act
of the speed of fiscal consolidation.
And as you all know, they have extremely high
public debt, in net terms, around 160 percent
of GDP.
So they have to do something about it.
But if they do it -- if they don't do it,
then credibility is in play, then, you know,
the rate on Japanese sovereign bonds will
go up.
And when you have 160 percent, and you have
to pay, say, 300 basis points more on each,
it becomes rather expensive and difficult.
So they have to avoid that.
At the same time, if they do too much, then
they kill growth in the short run, and then
things are not better.
So they have this really delicate balance,
which is, I think, going to be the issue for
Japan for -- for many years to come.
My text has appeared under me, so I have to
go back to it.
Three more.
I suspect I've exhausted my time probably.
Southern Europe.
And to me, this is still the place where there
is good reasons to worry.
The picture is mixed.
On the one hand, they are doing better on
the external side.
They have -- as you know, many of these countries
started with large current account deficits,
so they had to do something to with competitiveness.
And exports are going faster than the markets
are in.
So the market share is increasing.
That's good news.
The bad news is internal demand, which is
weak in some cases, actually going down.
And that's the result of a number of years
now of very weak activity, which has led to
weak firms, which has led to weak banks, which
forces more fiscal consolidation.
And there, we -- another analogy away from
accelerator and brakes, but adverse loops
are very powerful; which is if you have a
weak economy, then firms are weaker, banks
are weaker, they lend less, and so on, and
so on.
And I think there are still reasons to worry
there.
They haven't turned the corner.
I think this is going to be an issue for some
time.
Last, emerging markets.
So I think in general, we're fairly optimistic.
We have emerging markets growing at -- as
a whole, at 6 percent.
It seems to me that it's largely business
as usual.
And there are some countries which are overheating,
some countries which have shortfalls in demand,
some countries which have structural problems,
some not.
Brazil doesn't have enough investment.
India has administrative problems, which stand
in the way.
I think the big question probably from an
internal point of view is China, and whether
they're able to control the credit growth
at the rate at which they want; neither too
fast, nor too slow.
And this is not a trivial task for them.
In terms of the external environment that
they face, they're clearly going to face two
forces going in opposite direction.
The first one is to the extent that the U.S.
and other advanced economies are strengthening.
This will increase their exports to various
degrees, depending on how open they are, and
what they sell.
But it's clear that interest rates, financial
conditions, are going to become tighter.
And they are going to be facing capital outflows
for some time.
And there was a fairly large amount of a capital
inflows we saw over the last -- over the last
few years, which went there, because it was
unattractive in the U.S. When it becomes more
attractive in the U.S., it will go back.
I think we can expect this to happen.
The evidence is that it's going to happen
mostly from countries which are not in great
shape from a macro point of view.
So if your house is not in order, not only
do you have to repair it, but you have to
be ready for capital outflows, and that's
a challenge that some countries are going
to face.
In general, what the work we have done at
the Fund suggests that on net, the fact that
stronger growth in the U.S. is going to come
with high interest rates, is on net going
to be a good thing for emerging markets, that
they'll get more from the increase in exports,
than they'll be affected adversely by the
increasing interest rates.
On net tapering rate happens -- and it will
happen in response to the U.S. economy doing
better -- is probably a good thing.
But there's going to be a lot of controversies
about this for some time to come.
Just wondering about two more points, two
risks we should be worried about.
So let me indicate one risk I'm not terribly
worried about is tapering.
It seems to me that the exit from unconventional
monetary policy is conceptually not terribly
difficult to achieve; technically, not extremely
difficult to achieve.
But it has never been done.
We don't know exactly what the effect of measures
on rates are.
And so communication issues are going to be
very substantial, so that I expect -- episodes
maybe not of the magnitude we saw last May,
but something like this to happen again and
again.
I think -- I tend to think of this as bumps
in the road.
I don't see this as a systemic crisis coming
back.
But I suspect it's going to be a bumpy path,
but not more than that.
The other is euro deflation.
So again, in our baseline, we don't have deflation.
I think that's the only place in the world
in this stage where I worry about deflation.
We do not predict deflation, but we see this
as a risk.
And our models give us about a 10 percent
probability of deflation in the Eurozone this
year.
The swap, inflation swaps, euro inflation
swaps, give roughly the same number.
Why does it matter?
W Well, deflation is never very good, but
there is a particular aspect, which is important
for Europe, which is that countries in the
south have to become more competitive relative
to countries in the north.
And in a fixed exchange rate, the only way
you can do this is by having less inflation
than the average.
That's the only way you can actually become
more competitive.
Now, if the Eurozone has -- just take a number
-- 2 percent inflation, then you can have
zero inflation, and you'll improve your competitiveness
by 2 percent a year.
If the Eurozone has zero percent inflation,
then you have to have deflation yourself.
And deflation is a very costly thing.
It makes the real interest rates adjusted
for inflation higher, decreases real value
of the debt.
It probably has adverse income distribution
effects, so that the -- if there is deflation
on average in the Eurozone, then the adjustment
process, which I talked about for Southern
Europe, may be derailed.
And I think that's a very serious issue.
So that's a risk I worry about.
Let me stop here and take questions.
Good.
COHEN: (OFF-MIKE) force around the world,
giving us a sense of the likely outcomes,
but also very importantly, the potential risks.
And I'd like to address one of the risks that
you touched on very briefly.
And that is in the world's second-largest
economy, China, there are signs perhaps of
a deceleration.
We see that in manufacturing.
You mentioned concerns about this liquidity
adjustment there as well.
But if you could spend just a moment giving
us your thoughts in terms of the bigger changes
in China, that for the last two decades, the
Chinese government has pursued economic policies
focused on liquidity, heavy spending on infrastructure,
and of course, exports, benefiting from low
labor costs.
What is clear I think to many is that the
new leadership in China is looking in terms
of the new economic model; one in which they
need to rein in the liquidity, and also one
in which they build up domestic demand, rather
than just export demand, recognizing, for
example, that labor costs in China are perhaps
no longer the lowest in the region.
If you can give us some sense of what the
path might be.
You know, obviously, China, and other emerging
markets, bounced back pretty quickly from
the so-called taper tantrum last spring.
But there are nevertheless these longer-term
concerns about the adjustment in the Chinese
economic model.
BLANCHARD: Good.
Yes, I do not consider myself a specialist
of China.
But I try to follow what's going on there.
I would make four remarks.
The first one is in the short run, I think
the issue is how do they handle the growth
in shadow banking, and in social financing?
And the question is how much control do they
have on it, and what tools do they want to
use?
For example, do they let some local authorities
go bankrupt, taking the risk that this might
create contagion and have other effects.
How much control do they have on local governments
in telling them not to invest in this or that?
I think that's what they're confronted with.
And the sense is that they're making some
progress, but they don't have complete control
of the issue.
So it could go one way or the other.
They could be unable to control it, and then,
you know, we have more of a credit boom, and
then we know how this ends.
Are they controlling too well, and they get
recession by Chinese standards, which is probably
still fairly large positive growth rate, but
less than what we have.
Again, our forecast for China is 7.5 percent,
which is optimistic, but I think has a fairly
large distribution around it.
The second is on how serious the reformers
are.
And I think there, there's no question that
they are serious.
I think that everything we hear is that they
really think the current model based on very
high investment rates is coming to an end,
that they cannot continue.
They have to move away from it.
So I think that they are convinced that they
need to do something.
I think they have a sense of what they want
to do.
And again, this is completely outside of my
sphere of knowledge.
But people who look at the policy aspects,
seeing that they have the power to do it,
or at least more power to do it than any of
their predecessors for a long time.
The last point I would make is, it's clear
what has to happen.
Initially, we said they have to decrease the
current account surplus, move from external
demand to internal demand, and also move from
investment to consumption.
The current account surplus has decreased
quite a bit, I think -- we think largely for
structural reasons.
But the shift from investment to consumption
hasn't taken place yet.
It has to take place, I think, for social
unrest, social considerations, political considerations.
And if you look at the reforms that the third
plan had suggested of the earlier five-year
plan -- had suggested it looks as if it should
help go in that direction.
That's the assessment I have.
COHEN: OK.
Let's turn our attention to Europe.
Clearly, you expressed your concern that one
of the potential risks would be deflation
in Europe.
So let's drill down a little bit more in terms
of the actual growth and inflation expectations.
You indicated that core Europe is starting
to do better.
But even there, there's a very wide range,
the U.K. growing perhaps 2.4 percent, but
France, still under 1 percent.
What are the potential ways in which France
and some of the other nations can bolster
their domestic demand?
How do they address their labor problems in
terms of persistent high unemployment rates,
and so on?
BLANCHARD: So I think it's a case-by-case
thing.
For the U.K, one has a sense that the momentum
is there, so it's not obvious that they need
to do much more.
They still have an output gap.
They still have high unemployment.
But unemployment, as you know, is decreasing
very fast, and because productivity growth
is so dismal, so that any increase in output
leads to a large decrease in unemployment.
So I think for the U.K., the question is why
is productivity growth so low?
We've done some work on it.
Much of it comes from low productivity growth
in services, and not, terribly surprisingly,
from productivity growth or productivity negative
growth in the financial sector.
So, you know, I think this is part of reorganization
of the financial sector.
What exactly needs to be done there I think
is for people like you to say, rather than
for people like me.
But I think that in terms of demand, should
they do much more?
They have been very reluctant.
And that's true of many countries.
They have been very reluctant to do public
investment.
And it strikes us as -- not only in the U.K.,
but elsewhere -- as a good time to do public
investment.
Governments, states, can borrow at very, very
low rates.
And this is an environment in which a private
firm would think it's a good time to actually
bring forward some of the projects, and start
them now, rather than later.
COHEN: Isn't that also true in the United
States right now?
BLANCHARD: This is very much true of the United
States right now.
This is true of many, many countries.
Fiscal consolidation has partly taken the
form of a decrease in public investment.
We know it's unwise, but we know it's unavoidable,
because of the politics of it.
That's the easiest thing to cut.
And in many countries, we think public investment
is too low.
Turning to Germany, things are going reasonably
well.
But again, what is striking is how -- and
the current account surplus of Germany comes
largely from more or less a normal level of
saving, but very low investment, both private,
but even more so, public.
And there, I think that's another place where
there must be some highways which are not
in perfect shape, and they could do more on
the public-investment side.
This would be good for the short run, be good
for the long run.
For France, I think the issue is a bit different.
I think there has been -- if you look at France,
objectively, you look at the state of banks,
you look at the degree of competitiveness.
It's not perfect, but the current account
deficit is relatively small.
We should worry about it.
It's not a very big issue.
What's very striking about France is low level
of confidence of both households, which affects
consumption, and firms, which affects investment.
Where does this come from?
People say that there's a French dummy (ph).
A French fixed effect that the French are
always worried about the future -- I don't
know if it's true -- but basically, something
having to do with a lack of clarity of the
policy, which has been in place now for a
year.
There one can hope that -- you know, there
was a speech by the prime minister last week,
indicating a change of direction, and an attempt
to limit or decrease the level of spending,
public spending.
This strikes us as something very important.
I think France is one of these countries where
the level of spending relative to GDP is clearly
too high.
And it has effects on the degree of taxation,
which is needed, and people are reacting worse
and worse to these very high taxes.
So I think for France, it's clear that the
issue number one is to limit the size of the
state, and eventually decrease it.
So it's really a case-by-case answer.
COHEN: What about the longer-term consequences
of this protracted period of high unemployment?
BLANCHARD: So -- Larry Sum (ph) -- you know,
high unemployment was the major issue in Europe
in the 1980s.
And so Larry Summers and I worked on that
issue at length at the time.
And we introduced in economics, existed in
physics, the word "hysteresis," which is the
notion that if you have a very long period
of unemployment, then some people are going
to lose it, are going to lose the skills,
are going to lose the morale, are going to
lose what they need to do to become productive.
And so long period of high unemployment leads
to a higher equilibrium level of unemployment
after that, because some people just are not
employable.
I worked on this for 10 years, and concluded
that the effect was there, but maybe was not
dramatic.
I concluded that what had happened in Europe
was institutional hysteresis, which is that
in response to high unemployment, Europe had
introduced a number of labor market institutions,
such as employment protection, which themselves
led to a higher level of unemployment; that
that was really the channel, it had introduced
labor market institutions, which were bad.
I have not seen this happen in this crisis.
So I suspect that, for example, if you look
at long-term unemployment in the U.S., you
see that they can't get jobs.
And so you have to say, "Why?"
But one hypothesis is they are unemployable.
It's a bit unlikely that somebody who's been
out of work for nine months is unemployable.
What happens -- and that's something on which
I worked with Peter Diamond at MIT -- is the
notion that when an employer receives 50 applications,
he has to rank them in some way.
And he basically -- one of the criteria he's
going to use is how long have you been unemployed?
So that in a market which is very depressed,
the long-term unemployed don't have a shot,
at the back of the line.
When the market becomes better, then, you
know, you have to choose between people, who
have been long-term unemployed, you don't
have a choice – there is nobody above them.
The evidence is that they get the jobs.
Now, one very important thing.
There is one reform which will not lead necessarily
to more growth, but would be highly desirable
in Europe which has to do with employment
protection.
And let me take two minutes, because I think
it's an interesting story.
So when the '70s, the oil shocks came, and
unemployment increased, most governments in
Europe tried to limit the amount of layoffs.
They put employment protection, high severance
pay, complex, traditional processes for which
you'd have to go.
And if any of you has, you know, worked in
Europe, has had a firm in Europe, you know
how hard it is to get rid of people.
It became clear in the '80s and the '90s,
that this was excessive, that it was just
standing in the way of what's needed for an
economy to reallocate itself all the time.
So we had employment protection reforms, that
they took a very strange form.
They took the form of creating two types of
contracts.
So one was permanent contracts with extremely
high employment protection, and temporary
contracts with little or no employment protection.
So from the point of view of the firms, it
solved the problem.
You basically keep a core group of workers,
and then you adjust with the others.
From the point of view of the union people,
who tend to be the ones with the permanent
contracts, it protects them, because they
have this set of people that are fired before
they are, or laid off before they are.
But it's a catastrophe.
It's a catastrophe, because the people who
are -- who have the temporary contracts are
the young.
And so the lifecycle of the young at this
stage in Europe -- and this was already partly
true before the crisis, but worse now -- is
you start with a temporary contract if you're
lucky.
Then you get unemployment for a while, then
you get another temporary contract, another
one, so on and so on.
The firms which hire you do not feel any strong
incentive to train you, because they don't
have the right to keep you for more than 12
or 18 months, unless they transform your contract
into a permanent one, which they don't want
to do.
And so you have this dual labor market in
Europe, and this leads to unemployment rates
in Spain, as you know, for the younger, 50
percent.
Number's very similar in Italy.
That's a reform which has to happen, but you
can see how much resistance there is to it
from the point -- from the point of view of
the people with the permanent contracts.
So there's still progress being made, but
it is slow.
I don't think it's going to lead to a burst
in growth, but it's going to lead to much
fairer distribution of the burden.
COHEN: One final question from me before we
turn it to our other attendees, and it has
to do with the engagement of central banks
around the world, and how they view their
roles.
Clearly, the Federal Reserve was a standout
early in the global financial crisis, moving
forward with monetary policy of a very accommodative
sort, but also in terms of its supervisory
and regulatory functions, imposing tough love
on the U.S. financial system in the form of
very significant meaningful stress tests,
and so on.
And one of the concerns has been that other
central banks are lagging in this regard.
If you can give us an update, if you will,
in terms of the European Central Bank, the
way they view their role now, and also, touching
upon the change in structure there, where,
unlike early in the financial crisis and the
severe recession, the ECB now does have some
regulatory authority on individual financial
institutions.
BLANCHARD: So I think you're raising maybe
the number one issue in terms of the big issues,
big policy issues we have to think about for
the next 10 years or more, which is one of
the conclusions of the crisis is that you
cannot just control the economy with one rate,
the policy rate.
There had been a convergence in academia,
and to some extent, in central banks, that
the right monetary policy was you have a policy
rate, you have a target, which is inflation,
you have a policy rate, and you move the policy
rates by 25 basis points, this way and that
way.
And if you're good enough, everything is fine.
And we learned that you can do this, and everything
looks fine at some margin, and it's going
very wrong at another other margin, then you
get the financial crisis we got.
The conclusion is that we have to use macroprudential
tools, which is tools which are much more
specific.
If you're using it as a housing boom, you
don't use the policy rate, which affects the
whole economy, but you use the loan-to-value
ratio, a vice (ph) -- constraints on the capital
ratio associated with mortgages, for example.
That's very nice.
It's right.
It makes for an incredibly complex set of
arrangements, because basically the question
is where do you put these -- these new tools?
Conceptually, if you put them outside the
central bank, then you need coordination between
the two.
It's very complex.
So most countries have concluded that has
to be within the central bank in some form.
So, for example, in England, as you know,
there are two committees within the central
bank; one monetary, and one financial.
And they interact with each other within the
bank.
The issue is that the central banks -- is
now taking decisions which affect one group
or the other with very clear political implications.
Also, it is not entirely clear that the central
bank, which is independent, should be the
place which decides how much capital goes
to this, how much capital goes to that.
So both I think for conceptual and political
reasons, it's incredibly difficult to articulate
exactly what the powers of the central bank
should be, what limitations.
How do you basically put some democratic ownership,
while not eliminating the independence of
the central bank, and the central banks around
the world are struggling with this.
You said the U.S. had done great.
It did great earlier.
But If I look now at the system of financial
regulation, the macroprudential tools, it's
a mess.
But, other countries are exploring their ways.
You took the example of the ECB, which has
been tasked with finding what the health of
banks is, and then forcing these banks to
take measures.
This is an incredibly political job.
They are going to be under enormous pressure
here and there to do things.
And it's going to make for I think a very
complicated task.
I think we haven't solved that issue.
That issue is there.
It's going to be there for a while.
COHEN: Thank you very much.
And now we'd like to open the floor.
Yes, sir?
QUESTION: Paul (ph) (inaudible) chief economist
at Standard & Poor's.
Thank you very much for a very illuminating
talk and discussion.
I'd like to focus back on Europe.
I found it interesting that when you looked
at the Eurozone, you separated out the core
Europe, dealt with that, with the U.K., and
then came onto the periphery later.
But of course, the 17, now 18 countries in
the Eurozone are all in a single monetary
union.
And you touched on the issue of deflation
in the periphery.
But I wanted to sort of question you or get
your ideas about the architecture issue in
the Eurozone, and how you see that both as
an economist, a macroeconomist, and as a policymaker.
Big development in 2012.
Was the recognition at the highest level of
policymaking thinking in the -- being the
Eurozone -- that the Eurozone architecture
was fundamentally flawed, and it needed to
be fixed.
And plans were set out to move, in their words,
towards a genuine economic and monetary union
involving banking union, moves towards fiscal
union -- genuine economic integration, and
political union.
So seems to me that's one of the great sort
of issues of the day, which is going to really
be important as it unfolds over the next few
years.
I'd love to get your thoughts on -- as an
economist and policymaker, what you think
they should be doing in terms of the architecture,
and actually what Europe will look like, or
the Eurozone in particular, will actually
look like.
So perhaps the normative and a positive perspective?
Thank you very much.
BLANCHARD: I think from normative point of
view, we all understand what's needed.
So the banking union is clearly essential,
and there there is progress.
I think it will happen.
I think at least the initial exercise, which
is the so-called AQR, the stress test, will
take place.
There'll be recapitalization.
But as you know, we're not clear about the
-- how the -- where the money will come from,
if needed.
But I think that's a process which -- which
will take place eventually.
On the fiscal union, I think -- I expect -- again,
from a normative point of view, it is quite
-- it would be quite useful.
Let me, however, take a point here, that that's
not a panacea.
Some people say that the reason why the U.S.
works as a common currency area is because
of the fiscal structure, and the transfer
to the states.
That's playing some role.
But for the U.S., what makes the U.S. function
as a currency area is mobility, which is that
when a state is doing poorly, people leave
the state.
When a state is doing well, people go to that
state.
I did some work with Larry Katz many years
ago on that topic.
And to me, it's the dominant factor.
And that will never be the case in Europe.
So we'll never get to that point.
Even if you have these two, I suspect that
these may not be enough to control, say, a
housing boom in a country, or another, and
you may have to use macroprudential tools
as well.
And that's some of the issues I discussed
coming back in.
So from a normative point of view, all these
things are needed.
Even at the end, I'm not sure it would work
as well as the U.S., precisely for the reason
I have given, which is the lack of labor mobility.
It's -- even within countries, labor mobility's
much smaller than in the U.S., and across
borders, it is very limited.
From a descriptive point of view, I suspect
that there'll be slow progress on the banking
union, and very little else for the time being.
QUESTION: Dick McCormick, CSIS.
A couple of years ago, you were reported in
the media as favoring central banks, some
central banks moving from a 2 percent inflation
target to a 4 percent inflation target.
Are you still of this view, and if so, would
you give us the pluses and minuses of doing
this?
BLANCHARD: Obviously, no minuses.
No.
I made -- so I think there are two arguments
here.
I made the first one.
The question is how do I feel about the second
one.
The argument I made is that when there's an
adverse shock hitting the economy, you want
to have the ability to decrease the interest
rate a lot, conceptually.
How much you can do it depends on where you
are relative to zero.
So I argued that if you want an economy at
2 percent inflation, and the real rate on
average is 2 percent, then you're going to
typically start from 4 percent, 2 and 2, and
you have a 4 percent margin.
Once you decrease your rate to zero, that's
what you can do.
Then you have to go to unconventional monetary
policy and so on.
It doesn't work as well.
I argued that it might make sense to an economy
at 4 percent inflation, which will lead to
an interest rate of 6 percent.
And then you'd have 6 percent room to adjust
in case of an adverse shock.
I continue to think that if we'd had, say,
2 percent more to adjust the interest rate
in 2009 -- end of 2008, early 2009 -- it would
have helped.
So it's kind of an insurance policy.
There are going to be bad shocks once in a
while.
And you have a bit more margin if you operate
with, on average, a high interest rate.
You're able to decrease the real rate.
So that argument strikes me as right.
The question is, well, what -- you know, it's
like you pay your insurance -- your life insurance
policy.
You pay it every month for some event which
you hope will not happen for a long time.
Is it worth paying, right?
Is it worth having 4 percent rather than 2
percent?
And I argued that there's no solid evidence
anywhere in the world which shows that 4 percent
is substantially more costly than 2 percent.
The distortion's from inflation exist, but
they exist at higher rates of inflation.
So seemed to me that it was a useful insurance
policy to buy, and that when we get back to
some normal, I'd be happier to have it.
There's a separate argument which has been
made recently, which is not with respect to
macro, but with respect to fiscal, which is
we have a -- high debt levels.
And either it's going to be repaid by taxpayers,
or maybe it can be decreased in value for
inflation.
So some people argue that one way of doing
it is basically to have an inflation rate
which is higher, keep the nominal rate -- policy
rate low, so that in effect, the real rate
is negative.
And this allows you to decrease the debt level
more slowly.
But it allows you to decrease with that level
over time.
So this is using inflation to decrease the
debt level.
It seems to me that's a very dangerous route.
That's a very dangerous argument.
I can see it in situations in which things
are so desperate that it's either this or
default, in which case, you may want to have
a smooth default, relatively smooth default
for inflation, rather than an explicit default.
But I don't think that any country's anywhere
close to that.
QUESTION: Byron William Blackstone (ph).
You said that you expect China to grow at
about 7.5 percent.
But at the same time, they're trying to rebalance
the economy away from infrastructure and state-owned
enterprise investment spending toward the
consumer.
Now, my calculations show that there is no
way that they can accomplish that goal and
grow at 7.5 percent.
The growth has to slow.
So how are your calculations different from
mine?
BLANCHARD: I would never question your calculations.
I think that's a difference of horizons, which
is that this reallocation towards consumption
is going to be very slow.
So a 7.5 percent is for this year and next
year, in which this reallocation doesn't play
an essential role.
If we look forward to the type of distribution
of production, which we think they are aiming
at, which is higher consumption and higher
consumption of services, then you're completely
right in the sense that productivity growth,
at least measured productivity growth in services,
is lower than it is in manufacturing, so that
looking forward, say, five to 10 years, the
range is much closer to 6 percent than to
7.5 percent.
QUESTION: Thank you.
Nise Sagwa of Pace University.
My question relates to the reactions to the
tapering, and it has two parts.
The first is, do the markets, the financial
markets, react to flows or to stocks?
And it seems to me that even the Fed is not
very clear on that.
And the second is, is the effects of tapering
turn out to be very negative, will the Fed
try to increase the money supply by encouraging
banks to lend out their reserves, either by
having very low or negative interest rates
on reserve balances, or by some other measures?
Thanks.
BLANCHARD: So on the first, what do financial
markets react to, I think that's more a question
that you should be answering rather than I.
But I have a view, which is, you know, if
you look at what happened in May, I think
the reaction was not to a change in the flow.
It was in a change in the perceived path of
first, less buying, and then selling of assets.
And that was a reaction to, what I could call,
the "present value" of the whole path.
Basically, the markets decided that the Fed
was going to eventually slow down the rate
of purchase, and then turn around and sell
it.
So my sense is that the markets don't react
to flows – or to stocks.
They react to what they perceive as the whole
strategy of the Fed.
Now, clearly, when you decrease the flow,
you're giving an indication as to what you're
going to do later.
And that affects the behavior of people.
– In other words, it's not a mechanical
relation between putting $10 billion in the
market and getting 10 basis points.
That's just -- you put 10, this is a signal
of a path, and this leads to markets to adjust
the rate by 10 basis points.
It's a way to think about it.
I don't think it's an essential distinction.
On what would happen if the tapering was negative,
well, they would slow it.
And they really have no particular reason
to want to reduce their balance sheet extremely
quickly.
There's no obligation to reduce the balance
sheet quickly.
So I think in this case, they would basically
keep the balance sheet.
Now, the issue which would arise is if they
have to increase the interest rate at the
time they still have a very large balance
sheet, then they would have to pay interest
rate on the reserves in order to get people,
to get the banks to be willing to keep the
excess reserves.
And that would -- would present a cost, from
an accounting point of view, for the Fed,
by paying interest.
It would have, I think, from an economic point
of view, it's totally irrelevant.
It's basically a check to treasury.
We don't think that makes any difference.
But from a political point of view, that would
look bad.
If the Fed starts sending checks to banks,
I think that in the current political environment,
Congress, some people in Congress, would react.
So I think the issue is political, but I don't
see this as a major one.
(UNKNOWN): (OFF-MIKE)
BLANCHARD: That would have to pay positive
in order to keep the banks willing to keep
the reserves.
QUESTION: Thank you.
Carol Brookins (ph), former USCD, the World
Bank.
I'd like to ask you about energy and this
drag on Europe's economies.
Energy costs in Europe are double, that of
the United States.
Do you have any calculations on this impact
in terms of the drag on growth, particularly
in France, Germany, other countries?
BLANCHARD: I will admit utter ignorance of
the issue.
I do not know.
COHEN: Yes, in the back, please?
QUESTION: (Inaudible), U.S. companies have
posted a mixed picture in first quarter earnings
so far.
The earnings looks well, but the revenues,
not so good.
So what's its implication for the economy?
Thank you.
BLANCHARD: Again, to me, maybe incorrectly,
these are -- these are bumps.
These are not -- I mean, I think that U.S.
firms are doing well.
Profits are large.
One issue is why they are not investing more,
and I do not have a good explanation for that.
But the kind of numbers you gave doesn't worry
me.
COHEN: If I may interject, because these are
the sort of data that I do look at regularly.
I think it's much too early in this reporting
period to reach those sorts of conclusions.
We still have many companies in the S&P 500
left to report, point one.
Point two, it would appear that Mr. Blanchard
has really touched on very important long-term
issue, and that is U.S. companies have very
strong balance sheets; that is, the companies
in the S&P 500.
And the question is, how are they using their
cash?
And over the last few years, we've seen that
more than usual, about 10 percentage points
more than usual, have gone for things like
dividend increases and share purchases, and
that 10 percent has come out of things like
long-term investment and investment in research.
And that really is, I think, the long-term
question.
By the way, there is -- there are comparable
data points for the federal government.
The federal government is also investing much
less than it usually has invested in terms
of infrastructure, but also in terms of basic
research.
Just by way of example, the U.S. government
used to invest 4.5 percent of GDP in things
like basic research and R&D.
We're now down to 2.5 percent.
That is not what it needs to be, in my view.
BLANCHARD: But the reasons for public and
private investment being low has been different.
What is your main guess as to why firms are
reluctant to do long-term investment?
Is it -- is it uncertainty of some sort, about
how the world looks like in five years?
Or is it something else?
COHEN: There are many theories out there,
some people talking about uncertainty.
I think the number one reason is the output
gap with capacity utilization rates in the
United States finally -- finally moving up
to the point where new investment would be
encouraged.
The other thing that we are watching very
carefully, and the data look better over the
last few months, is the creation of new jobs
in the private sector.
We always look at that headline number in
terms of jobs created.
Let's keep in mind the public sector has cut
back 600,000 or 700,000 jobs.
But there is now much better job creation
taking place in the private sector in the
United States.
I think we have time for one more quick question.
I think we're good.
I would like to thank Monsieur Blanchard for
being here on behalf of all of us, and for
a wonderful discussion this morning.
BLANCHARD: Thank you very much.
(APPLAUSE)
END